[Applaudissements]
quand je suis monté à mahdia l'aubrac
je sais pas si c'est un bon présage que
dieu soit avec toi et je suis ravi
d'être là même si un petit peu comme le
jeune homme qui est passée totalement je
sais pas trop ce que je fais je ne sais
pas si j'ai fait quelque chose qui
mérite mais je vais vous raconter un peu
mon prénom je m'appelle saner aux mêmes
je suis né en france de parents
tunisiens originaires de ternat mon père
comme tous les épiciers et est délimitée
comme tous les tueurs bien tard dans
l'été puisiez c'est un lapsus révélateur
et on était une fratrie de six enfants
donc moi je voulais juste vous annoncer
que vous verrez rien sur sur l'écran non
pas parce que j'ai pas préparé mais
parce que je n'ai envie que vos regards
sont focalisés sur moi parce que c'est
mon travail itt attirer l'attention
pourquoi est-ce que c'est contraire à en
attirer l'attention pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai commencé à faire ça je pense que
c'est parce que comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure on était six enfants
j'étais la numéro 5 il fallait trouver
sa place ma place s'était attiré
l'attention de faire le pitre à chaque
fois et j'ai fini par en fermant mais
tire alors la première fois je suis
remonté sur scène j'avais 12 ans c'était
pour à l'atelier théâtre au collège et
on m'a demandé tu vois une improvisation
c'était le thème c'était de jeu j'étais
une jeune fille pour nos copains
viennent se faire écraser par une
voiture
c'est très bien organisé
et j'ai tellement réussi à entraîner du
personnage et à croire que j'étais ce
personnage je démocrate a situation que
je réussis à pleurer et interpol tout
classement des ce journal je me suis dit
c'est ça que j'ai envie de faire faire
pleurer les jeux peuvent or je sais ce
que je voulais en fait c'était s'était
transformé par des émotions c'était les
vivres et bien consentir à ce qui est et
qui étaient autour et qu'il était là
pour écouter je me suis dit je vais
essayer de le faire au mieux
donc j'ai commencé théâtre au collège
jean-mermoz lycée j'en ai fait à la fac
et après j'ai effacé le conservatoire
quand j'ai passé le concours pour entrer
au conservatoire de théâtre à paris et
sur le 21 on prenait 4 personnes j'ai
fait partie de ces 80 je pensais pas
pouvoir être prise parce que moi j'ai
grandi en banlieue parisienne dont 593
une ville tristement connue qui
s'appelle clichy-sous-bois des gens
dedans vous êtes reconnaître parce que
c'est là pour commencer les rênes du
club en 2005 les gens appellent ça les
élus le ca de la voiture de l'année et
du coup par mois tous débarqué dans ce
monde là j'étais jeudi un peu étonné je
pensais pas qu'on allait me prendre
et quand j'ai passé l'audition j'ai fait
avec le coeur gmj écran lui ça a
fonctionné on appris j'ai passé deux ans
au conservatoire
et puis ce qui s'est passé ce cas côté
je travaille pour essayer de gagner ma
vie parce qu'à mon âge je voulais pas
m'enfermer par up de donner de l'argent
de poche
et comme je travaillais je n'ai pas
assez assidus auront alors un jour les
profs on m'a dit écoute je suis désolé
des conflits mais dans la ville soit
tués soit tu fais du théâtre et bien
comme on peut le voir j'ai choisi de
monter voilà j'ai géré c'est un petit
peu la salle
et en sortant du conservatoire quand il
est entièrement commerciaux ou deux ans
ou disons que je n'ai pas assez assidus
rencontre et à ce qu'on voit là j'ai
rencontré un magnifique et converti à
l'islam
tu m'as appris ma propre région moi
j'avais hérité d'un muscle à culturelle
complète
alors viens nous apprenez que ces termes
de manger du nord de bordeaux d'alcool
et de coucher avec des garçons qu'est ce
que je fais mais je présume pas et qu'il
fallait faire le ramadan c'est tout et
quand je demandais mais pourquoi ça papa
thorax et c'est aussi comme ça c'est pas
trop mon locaux début que tu comprenais
pas trop
et quand je vois contrainte garçon il a
pris ou de laque la peur l'amour de dieu
et l'amour de dieu c'était autre chose
ça donnait envie de s'y intéresser
quand on aime quelqu'un on peut faire
des kilomètres à 5 heures du matin pour
aller lui chercher des croissants à
votre blague c'est pas une contrainte
c'est un plaisir il s'avère qu'on fait
quand il mal à la concerne à prendre ma
propre religion lui qui était convertie
et m'a donné envie de la pratique et
j'ai commencé à me renseigner petit à
petit au début mais quand vous venez
d'entendre parler de ce qui ressemble à
tout le monde connaît sûrement une
stature je me compte a gâché le monsieur
n'a plus des ordres sur la peur que tu
provoques rouge
ça a été très dur on a bataillé pendant
quatre ans surtout nous as tu avais
demandé à ses conservateurs comme
originaire de nice est souvent comme ça
mes parents ont fait que marianne qu'un
tunisien me dire vrai si possible que la
famille comme ça en fait des enfants
consanguins c'est génial et du bouveret
j'ai choisi une autre option c'était un
garçon qui venait de 8000 kilomètres de
là alors il a été entendu pour eux au
départ d'accepter il voulait pas en
entendre parler
mais pour moi c'était lui et personne
d'autre c'est comme si j'avais dessiné
nomi des halles que tu lui avait donné
la vie qui m'a dit james et qu'elle
maintient ses gains et meurant et ce
garçon n'a il a changé la vie
à partir de cette rencontre j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser
petit peu plus à la religion et puis un
jour j'ai décidé de porter le foulard et
quand j'ai apporté voile islamique
manière un peu plus traditionnel
merci moment là objectivement pas
maintenant la cnce prix ni combien ça
vaut vraiment acquis vraiment très rare
j'avais ces théâtres de beauté pense
qu'on peut jamais vendre jouer et puis
enfin prendre avec le théâtre sur scène
ce tony g qui portèrent durement comores
avec un col roulé elle s'appelait aussi
samian et elle jouer la comédie c'est
d'empêcher avec se joue des rames et à
ce moment là j'ai compris que les
barrières et c'était dans ma tête
west face beaucoup tu es donc j'ai
décidé de monter sur scène pour apporter
ma propre histoire et ça a commencé en
propre ça fonctionnait et suite à ça
j'ai pu achever en transit en belgique
suisse luxembourg au maroc en tunisie en
algérie au sénégal au gabon après tu
vois à montréal à dublin ouais ça fait
pas mal mais j'avais l'impression que
les médias généralistes ne
s'intéressaient pas ce que j'avais à
dire
de temps en temps je faisais des petites
vidéos sur le net en fonction ce qui
touche l actualité et avoir une vidéo
qui a fait le plus de buzz que les
autres où je parlais des islamistes
intégristes islamistes planus et qui est
cette vidéo elle est sur le net je vous
avais envie d'aller regarder mais cette
vidéo bizarrement alors demandé
attentats de charlie hebdo
elle avait beaucoup parler d'elle les
gens qui ont vu cette maman arabe qui
disait ogier à disque laissez nous
tranquille malgré le fait qu'elle soit
musulmane donc important voile et bien
ça non les gens d'accord
tous les jours on en a marre de ces gens
la trouvent les bouder morizet qui
faisait peut-être un peu d'amalgamé
entre l'islam et ça ce terrorisme ont
commencé à être un petit peu plus après
c'est peut-être grâce à cette vidéo à la
race avec pas mal de gens
et on en demande de la diffusion cette
vidéo j'étais invité sur tous les
plateaux tv sur le temps toutes les
radios un peu plus généraliste et là on
a commencé à parler mon travail bon
après je vais être sincère avec vous
c'est quand même laborieux parce que
chaque fois qu'on m'en vais dans une
émission de télé en france on parle
toujours de la musulmane monnaie qui
fait de l'humour
j'espère qu'un jour on fera plus
attention à cette issue est considérable
on considère à juste que je suis
humoriste mais j'essaie de faire du
mieux que je peux quand j'ai recommencé
la scène après avoir eu cette fille sur
scène avec ses amis m'ont donné envie de
chanter
la première fois que je suis raide
demandé pour remonter pour faire un
sketch est ce que moi j'étais juste
comédienne a la base je vais pas
d'humour et j'avais commencé à écrire un
sketch et je voulais le tester quelque
part la première personne à qui je me
suis présenté
elle m'a dit norman éclipse est pas
comme ça si tu devais un jour et
chimiques ont proposé une bande démo je
me faire un cv une lettre de motivation
[Musique]
j'ai toujours joué dans une classe
et donc à partir de ce moment là je me
suis dit mais non en fait je vais
parmentier c'est un mois à les supplier
pour compte assurer quelque part je vais
organiser moi-même et rentre en plateau
d'humour comme ça j'aurai besoin de
demander à personne j'ai un peu denis
francoeur qui sont algériens sans saveur
mais du coup j'ai organisé mon contre
plateau du monde et ça a fonctionné
j'ai fait plein de gens rentrent en
d'humoristes qui venaient faire rire
avec une règle c'est de ne pas de
vulgarité pas d' obscénité pour que les
femmes puissent donner au théâtre je
leur ai expliqué que nous dans notre
culture et qu'il y avait une scène
déplacer à la télé ou ont changé la
chine parce qu'on était mal à l'aise et
que aller voir des spectacles sa part
gonzague la cinquième set à nous
déplacer
donc du coup j'ai expliqué à tous et
humoriste là qui était de plein
d'origine différente qu'il faudrait
s'adapter au concept que je vais la
décrire ils ont accepté et maintenant
c'est des gens qui sont qui sont très
très connu en france et dans toute
l'europe
mais les clients qui m'ont fait
l'honneur de venir faire un passage sur
les spectateurs c'est plateau d'humour
que j'organisais donc j'ai fait ça
d'abord pour rendre à tester les droits
pour sketches et petit à petit j'ai
commencé à écrire davantage et je devais
avoir 15 minutes de scènes quelque chose
comme ça quand un jour un copain
comédiens m'appelle s'appelle fils d'un
monde c'est lui qui a été le premier qui
m'a fait monter
son dessert angie ça vient est ce que tu
peux avoir une urne de spectacles dans
trois films c'est impossible
tu dis ça fait deux ans je tourne avec
15 minutes
c'est impossible une dizaine d'heures
pour une heure de scène et prennent en
charge qu'en france porte à
l'hébergement c'est pour aller jouer aux
côtés c'est moi de jouer au luxembourg
pardon et s'est payé une fortune le sag
ardemment tu sais quoi de mangement des
bonheurs 2 0 j'écris je me suis fait
serrer la ceinture
moi je sais je sais travailler que dans
l'urgence est capable contrainte sinon
je sais pas faire et donc j'ai cru il
n'y a pas que le talent et la première
fois que j'ai joué c'est au luxembourg
je crois en 2011
ça s'est bien passé et puis j'ai
continué j'ai joué la peur de rater
bruges dans band donc lente événements
partout je suivais a cependant des
blazers j'ai beaucoup fait des choses
associative que je me rendais en finale
j'ai tellement joué pour les autographes
dès maintenant que j'ai demandé ce qu'il
en reste
mais c'était cool moi je me rappelle que
ma mère elle arrêtait pas de vous dire
moi je comprends pas d'y jeter le temps
gratuit si peu importe comment attirer
spam et anti responsabilité des switchs
je voudrais je dis moi combien gratuit
quoi qu'il arrive toujours gagner tu
fais une bonne action puisque cela ne
répond pas toi ton attention c'est de
faire une bonne action
donc ça c'est déjà positif de 2 tu
t'entraînes moi quand je joue à droite à
gauche ça me permet d'apprendre
davantage on travaille et de
perfectionnement spectacle de 3 ça te
créer un réseau donc plus tu vas jouer
plus les chances d'entendre parler de
toi et puis il ya des montres il a de
quoi d'être et plus ton travail va
prendre forme
donc quoi qu'il arrive y'a rien qui
graduent avant votre sapin géant très
réussi à la convaincre
et j'ai continué comme ça pendant un an
aujourd'hui j'ai eu la chance de jouer
on n'entend pas 104 du point virgule ces
anti théâtre qui se trouve dans le
quartier du marais à paris où ont débuté
beaucoup de grands artistes comme les
concours comme gad elmaleh comme lors
d'autres comédiens bigard et c est
pourquoi c'était une fierté pour
n'accepte pire entre amis dans ce
spectacle donne moi la fille du maigri
maintenant j'aimerais être bloqué en
théâtre à république un peu plus grand
j'ai la chance le chemin des médias je
joue trois soirs par semaine c'est
génial et un jour il a carrément une
maison d'édition j'ai pu voir en
spectacle ils ont complètement dominé ce
que je pressentais sur scène parce que
mon spectacle je faisais de
rassemblement je me moque et n'a pas
tout le monde mais pour mieux les venir
et donc ils sont tellement aimé ce que
représente et qui m'ont proposé d'écrire
un livre
alors au début j'ai dit pourquoi pas on
va tester
je vais essayer une autre aventure et
puis plus 1000 kwh approché lui disais
pourquoi j'ai dû me pousser à me poser
toutes vos questions j'ai fait des
crises d'urticaire jeu l'entente mais
plus la nuit la tête neymar exe et je
veux demander est-ce que j'étais
légitime parce que c'est ça notre
problème avec les filles on se pose
beaucoup de question de nous répondre et
légitime est quelque chose pour laquelle
le sentiment d'imposture et autres
produits surtout chez les armes c'est
que nous impose la milliards de
questions on cherche juste à avoir buté
à faire ce qu'on leur affaire on
n'arrête pas de ces martelé avec des
questions est ce que je vaux la peine
est ce que je méritais ce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui était pour moi est ce
que alors qu'un classement et se pose
pas de question
son objectif est marina pense et puis
c'est tout mais nous on est un peu plus
calme après tout à faire de généralités
assurant lectrices pose des questions en
utilisant ce pas mais moi je trouve pas
on va dire une main et est donc je me
suis posé beaucoup de questions depuis
notre je pense que ça va essayer de
donner le meilleur de moi même
j'écris en qu'un qui a sorti en mars
dernier et quand il est sorti dans les
premiers jours on est en rupture de
stock chez amazon j'ai un peu halluciné
parce que je m'attendais pas du tout à
ça et j'ai eu beaucoup de retours
positifs de gens qui disent mes nerfs
parce que ton histoire à l'inspirante
elle me pousse à donner le meilleur de
nous mêmes et à essayer de tracer notre
propre sol donc effectivement sur marc
tuer tous rencontré des problèmes des
galères des choses qui l'empêchait
d'avancer mais je me suis toujours dit
c'est pas grave moi mon objectif c'est
ça je vais tout faire pour les
explosions et j'ai donné mon millions de
moi même et je les aimais pas trop pour
que ça puisse fonctionner et donc sur
tous les plans j'ai galéré pendant que
l'homme que j'aimais la table 80
patience de pleurs de cris des
hurlements dans be de suicide et à la
forme au moment où je croyais peut-être
le moment les parents ont fini par
accepter la scène c'est la même chose
il m'arrivait normand galère sur la
route gens qui vont fermer des portes et
que c'est pas grave je suis cassé dans
ta fenêtre est en fait je pense que
c'est ça qui est important c'est de
charger laissé tomber de toujours
vouloir arriver forme puisque on a
décidé de faire il ya autre chose aussi
c'est quand même moi je reste convaincu
que le monde nous revois ce que nous on
lui envoie moi par exemple je suis né à
paris et à paris on sait que les gens au
presque toute l'année c'est triste et
dans les transports en commun ont tué la
tête les gens semblaient pas ils ont le
train train quotidien le stress tout un
tas de choses et moi jamais
comme ça on a fait tous les jours je
suis toujours souriante mais c'est à
quelques exemples aussi que plus
agréable que possible
et bizarrement en face de moi il
m'arrive de belles choses et je suis
convaincu qu'en fait la file saad baisse
de retour c'est un miroir que les gens
vont rentrer si vous leur donner le
meilleur de vous même si vous essayez de
faire du mieux que vous pouvez et pourra
vous arriver que de belles choses là
j'en suis convaincu et puis aux dames le
chemin on sait qu au début c'est pour ça
que je me pense que je fais là mais je
suis ravi parce qu'il m'arrive plein de
choses que je n'aurais jamais imaginé à
la fin de l'année dernière 26 faire un
classement des sentences français les
plus influents au monde et une nuits
dont j'avais un prix ils m'ont invité à
une soirée chez conti j'ai passé la
soirée à les voir chaque jour le maximum
pour moi donc je réside entre nous a
probablement choisir parce que vous avez
du talent qu'est ce que la bd est bon je
faisais que j'avais même pas les croire
at il simplement dit 48e succès quand je
dis est vrai que d'être dans les 50
minutes il m'a dit et 48e sur 140 les 50
français le plus en ce moment tu tu
mérite d'être considérée comme française
quelque temps plus tard j'ai été invité
à faire partie de la délégation
présidentielle du président français qui
venaient rencontrer président tunisien
je fais un prix juste dit quand j'y suis
allé je me suis dit puisque moi fille
d'épicier
je vais ici dans un palais présidentiel
et c'est fou mais j'ai comme
l'impression que ces dix années de
carrière où j'ai essayé d'y planter des
graines elles finissent par incolore
maintenant donc je pense que vraiment
comme le disait les autres speaker il
faut absolument rien
croire en quelque chose que nous donner
les moyens de réussir ce qu'aurait été
la seule personne qui peut vous empêcher
d'atteindre nos buts c'est vous même
voilà simplement
[Applaudissements]